j moins 3 avant le départ du paris nice
cette course cycliste partira pour la
onzième année consécutive des yvelines
le peloton s'élancera depuis le village
départ du château de plaisir ce dimanche
8 mars pour une boucle de 154 km au
début on va faire une grande boucle on
va passer par poignées des forêts
montfort l'amaury mais après on va on va
tourner vers crêpier affaires moule
remonter toutes les petites côtes et
entre chaque coup tu y as des longues
lignes droites qui a pas d'arbres il ya
du vent donc bon voilà on a faim on a
été chercher la difficulté le lendemain
le lundi à midi 25 des parts depuis
chevreuse communes de moins de 6000
habitants
direction le loiret pour cette deuxième
étape une petite commune qui est mise en
avant donc nous au niveau aux structures
sont des structures sont beaucoup moins
imposante prenez le départ et d'aller à
chevreux c'est parfait parce que
cheuvreux c'est un peu paradis du vélo
c'est un peu du cyclisme des cyclistes
qui roulent tous les dimanches vous voir
toute la semaine donc c'est un peu
l'histoire du vélo sur le plan sportif
des imprévus de dernière minute pour et
assombrir cette course au soleil
malgré la présence a annoncé les têtes
d'affiché comme julian alaphilippe
quatre équipes cyclistes ont déclaré
forfait à ce jour ineos endeuillée par
le décès de son directeur sportif
nicolas portal mais également miquel
tonnes et astana ultime emirates pour
cause de corona virus cette édition
devrait tout de même être maintenue pour
l'instant il n'est pas question
d'annuler paris nice sauf si l'épidémie
se propage
bon là pour l'instant comme certaines
grandes rencontres là ce jour le paris
nice a lieu le départ de cette 78e
édition est donc pour l'instant
programmé ce dimanche 8 mars à 11h05
depuis plaisir le village départ sera
quant à lui installé devant le château à
partir du samedi 7 mars 9h